Speaker 1: Well, we now know that Republicans
have won the House in the 2022 midterms and will
control the House of Representatives for a two
year period. It will be Hunter Biden 24 seven.
It may be Joe Biden impeachment. How do we know?
Well, I'll show you in a moment. If you needed
any more sense of what to expect, though, you
need look only over to the Senate and what 37
Republican senators there did in voting against
recognizing codifying same sex and interracial
marriages. It's 2022. It's not 2002 or 1992
or 1922. But 37 Republican senators said,
let's not codify federal recognition of same sex
and interracial marriage. And that tells us a lot
about what we can expect in the House. Now, one
important thing to mention, at the end of the day,
we had shifting forecasts, polls being molded like
putty. We didn't know well which scenario, the
most likely scenario going into the midterms was
Democrats hold the Senate but lose the House. And
that's exactly what happened. Now, of course, it
was a circuitous path to get there, but the final
result in the 30,000 foot view is exactly what we
expected. Now, in terms of the Biden impeachment,
Hunter Biden investigations, these are really
not maybes, first and foremost. Jim Jordan will
become chair of the House Judiciary Committee
when this new Congress is sworn in. A disgrace,
a humiliation, but a very clear sign of what is
to come, because we know all about Jim Jordan's
interests in irrelevant stories like Hunter
Biden. Secondly, we are going to see people
like Marjorie Taylor GREENE now spend two years
trying to impeach Biden, probably three or four
times a week. And the hope has to be that
the American people overall and, you know,
when there are so many people who have been
successfully targeted by weaponized propaganda,
that they will believe that impeaching Biden
and investigating Hunter Biden makes sense as
judicial prior legislative priorities, House of
Representatives priorities. But the hope has to
be that most people realize investigating Hunter
Biden does nothing for me about inflation or wages
or health care or whatever the case may be. Many
of us saw this coming. There's no question about
it. But it is now abundantly clear that it is
going to be Hunter Biden 24 seven. Just as a
couple of examples for you. Over on Twitter, the
House GOP Twitter account has spent much of the
last 24 hours tweeting about Hunter Biden. And
as you scroll down and look at the things here,
Joe Biden is the big guy. They tweeted, big guy
is a reference to a Hunter Biden story in which
they say Joe Biden is referred to as the big
guy who's getting a cut of something. You know,
these conspiracy theories that they have. They
then posted a clip of an interview with Hunter
Biden again. They're obsessed with Hunter Biden.
Then before that, this is all the last hour,
by the way, as I'm filming. Then they posted a
link to a Fox News article about Hunter Biden.
Then they posted a picture of Joe Biden allegedly
meeting Hunter Biden's Kazakh business associate.
Then previously, they had posted another clip
from an interview with Hunter Biden and more
pictures of the Biden family. I'm not going to
waste the entire segment talking about this, but
going on and on and on. And then, by the way, this
morning, a Fox News covered a press conference in
which Republican Congressman James Colmer declared
that the Hunter Biden that Hunter Biden himself is
going to be at the center of investigations to be
carried out by the Republican House. So there's
two ways to look at this. One, these people are
obsessed with Joe and Hunter Biden in a way that
makes no sense. Hunter Biden is not an elected
official. He's not running for anything. He has
nothing to do with the administration, contrary
to Ivanka and Jared, who did have things to do
with the Trump administration, that people
are going to see through it and they're not
going to go for it. The counterpoint would be,
Hey, Republicans have a solution to just about
every problem. Inflation. Well, we're going
to subpoena Hunter Biden. Gas prices are too
high. Subpoena Hunter Biden. What do we do about
housing or China or health care or immigration or
whatever? Police we're investigating. Hunter
Biden and. Maybe we're even impeaching Joe
Biden. Will much of the country fall for it? I
don't know. I don't know. Now, if we want to put
the best possible spin on this and by this,
I mean Republicans taking the House, making
it clear they're going to spend two years mostly
focused on Hunter Biden. This is going to be the
slimmest of slim majorities for Republicans in the
House. And you could make the case that this will
expose their B.S., their obsession with irrelevant
things like Hunter Biden, such that in 2024,
it will be very helpful to Democrats in taking
back a sizable majority. That's the sort of rose
colored glasses view on this. They'll have
just enough power to look bad, but hopefully
not enough power to cause major destruction. I
don't know. It's really a predictive question.
And as I've told you before, humans are pretty
bad at making predictions. The upshot of the
obsession with the Hunter Biden stuff is, yeah,
FOX News is going to talk about it all the time,
but I don't think the American people, generally
speaking, are obsessed with Hunter at all. It's a
sliver of the right that cares about Hunter.
And so we'll see where it all shakes out.